one of the most common things I get
asked is how do I know if I'm bad enough
in therapy well the first thing is if
you're asking me am I bad enough for
therapy your answer is not yes you're
bad enough but it means you need therapy
I think everyone can benefit again it's
like going to the gym and saying I've
got the gym mastered I know how to use
everything in here there's no way I can
improve my training techniques if so why
why do we bother having training athlete
trainers and stuff like that and you
know pts for Olympians and why are they
continuously mastering the art of the
the techniques we can all learn and if
you can feel 10 happier wouldn't you
think that's worth that in your day I
mean most of us would like to feel a
little bit less suffering and a little
bit happier so if anyone's listening to
this and going oh I don't know if
therapy is for me I really think
everyone could benefit from it